this is a forgotten front line in a
hidden battle it is where the old and
frail find themselves in the fight of
their lives this isn't a hospital ward
it's a nursing home and this is what a
single day inside one looks like 24
residents here have COBIT 19 3 have died
this week alone including an elderly
lady overnight unfortunately she
deteriorated quite steadily we had daily
reviews with the doctor daily clinical
observations and unfortunately she lost
her fight with coffered last night it's
heartbreaking it's heartbreaking as a
nurse as part of a care team when
anybody loses their life it's
heartbreaking when the families can't be
here because of we have positives in the
in the building we made sure that we had
a staff member in with this lady at all
times so she wouldn't die alone
each resident with coronavirus must stay
inside their room and nurses must put on
plastic aprons masks and gloves before
they go inside hi John John's already
ill but coronavirus could kill him and
the nurses try their best to make him
comfortable but it's obvious he isn't
and his health is deteriorating by the
hour so I'm just washing my hands and
after being in a room with a gentleman
it was perfect positive
the nurses here have accepted that they
can't help everyone right now it feels
horrific knowing that we're not doing
enough for them and we're trying our
best where he was in everything that
suggested for its use and it's not
enough and that's heartbreaking really
yeah we even got to our worst point you
know another coronavirus patient is
Charles he ended up in hospital after
suffering a fall to free up beds he was
transferred here and at some point he
caught the virus he might be ill but he
knows what he wants this home is now in
full lockdown the doors have been closed
in just a few weeks the activities to
socializing the crafts clubs and the
music have all come to an end and
everyone's being kept apart at a cost
all this masks and so the mask goes on
again it is a ritual repeated time and
again
[Music]
the personal protection equipment or PPE
is all the nurses have to protect
themselves from others but they don't
have enough mid-nineteen isn't a
surprise it's not happened overnight we
knew that it would come in why we're
having to struggle to get this equipment
in place is it's appalling really John
is not getting any better he says he
doesn't want to be here anymore and a
delicate conversation begins Claudia is
a student nurse and has been thrown into
the middle of this crisis and she does
her best to explain what's happening as
soon as the text people your test
results come back that you're not
positive anymore we can discharge you
the number of people who are infected
with culvert 19 is rising by the day
here and there are severe staff
shortages too because like the residents
the staff are being infected now big
decisions are being made about who
should receive potentially life-saving
care and who shouldn't a GP meets with
nursing staff to discuss patients whose
conditions are getting worse it is a
grim moment where difficult decisions
are made
to go to hospital if there was a
disarray and potentially have treatment
or potentially and life in hospital or
[Music]
would they want to stay here potentially
and as comfortable as possible
[Music]
yeah it's tough it's not easy
John's condition continues to worsen and
the care team decide he should stay in
the home so far deaths from coronavirus
in care homes have not been included in
the official figures it is thought
thousands have died in places like this
and have gone uncounted it is a hidden
death toll but the lives that have ended
in the shadows of this crisis ignored in
Sky News Sheffield